well I made that three o'clock so uh
let's get started
uh my name's Ian Cooper uh my various
socials are
there on the screen in front of you
um my DMs on Twitter are open and I'm
usually very happy to take uh
uh communication from you folks if
you've got specific questions you want
to ask kind of afterwards
this talk today is about reactive
architectures
so uh a brief overview would be we're
going to look at what we mean by
reactive
reactive programming and reactive
systems and really how the insights of
reactive programming can help us build
uh better architectures
that's just me uh it essentially says
I'm old
um I always write the bottom point which
is
you know I got into this gig years ago
because of speaking because uh I started
a.net user group and there was nobody
that could speak about.net because we
did it in 2002 when it was still in
betas we had to do it ourselves so I got
used to the idea of standing in front of
an audience and speaking but it's not
I'm not here because I'm smarter I just
had the opportunity to build up the
confidence to do it so please uh think
about doing it yourself it's definitely
worthwhile
any.net developers in the room
yeah it's good there's a whole load of
us at one place
um I work on an open source project
called brighter it's a messaging
framework primarily competes with mass
transit and then service bus we are also
effectively a what we call a command
processor which effectively competes
with things like mediator uh we predate
mediator by some time but you've
probably never heard of us but please do
check us out
we don't have as good PR as Jimmy
all right
let's talk about the reactive Manifesto
first of all just so we can get clear
um kind of what our scope is has anyone
heard of the reactive Manifesto I've
seen it yeah quite a few of you okay
so the ratchet manufacturer came out in
2014 and it was basically by Jonas
Bonner but there's a few luminaries of
the industry that helped him uh kind of
write it and I'm sure you recognize some
of the names in there
um
and
they wanted to create a a new
architectural style called reactive
applications
inspired a lot by the ideas that came
from reactive programming
and they had some characteristics they
were trying to achieve they wanted to
create applications that would react to
events
so they wanted to be event driven
because it had the following qualities
they felt that being event-driven would
let essentially them write applications
which scaled to load more easily
that they would be resilient to failure
and that they would be able to be
responsive to users so in other words as
users effectively were added to the
system we would continue to be able to
respond to them in a timely fashion
and they essentially said these
properties are valuable being responsive
system responds in a timely manner
resilient the system stays responsive in
the presence of failure elastic the
system stories responsive under varying
workloads and message driven we rely on
asynchronous message passing and often
we use this diagram to represent that
so the idea is by the means of being
message driven
we are able to achieve properties of
elasticity and resilience
which both in turn work together to make
us responsive to users
now this talk is not
about a specific reactive programming
model
we will go through them but I'm not here
to tell you about you know akka Orleans
or a given active framework right so
that's what you've come for there is
still time to exit the building
but we will talk about reactive
programming and what the models that
basically fall under that heading
to understand how we can use those ideas
to achieve those properties in reactive
architectures so the first half we'll
talk about
um reactive programming we'll talk about
data flow active model and flow-based
programming in theory CSP communicating
sequential processes is also really a
reactive programming model but I'm not
going to cover that today
and then we'll get into reactive systems
what are the principles and patterns we
can use to achieve those properties in
the large
but there's a key idea to all of this
which is probably expressed by the Greek
philosopher heraclitus I will try the
ancient Greek it's going to be awful
apologies to anyone Greek in the
audience I think it's tarpantare Kai
uden menai which means everything flows
and nothing stays
and the idea is that we want to focus on
flow
what's important to us when we think
about a system and how we model it and
how we deal with how we decide it's
architecture
is the flow of information through the
system
how is that a contrast to what you may
be doing today all right
so we're talking about objects in SOI
that's not the world we want to live in
and we will talk about what the problems
are from that world from the point of
view of moving to a larger canvas
then we'll get into reactive we'll run
through some of the ideas and reactive
programming and then towards the end
we'll see how we can apply them to
systems
so I'd expect nearly all of us are
familiar with the idea of
object-oriented programming
so an opportunity program we have a
class and a class Loosely we could
Define as a role in our system it has
responsibilities
actually and it has essentially to
fulfill those responsibilities some
behaviors and some state
and usually the idea is that the state
we encapsulate and hide
which is the state required to exhibit a
given set of behaviors there's usually
coupling between the behaviors in the
class and the state of the class
basically manages and it owns
and our system tends to consist of a
number of these classes that basically
pass messages to each other in in
objectorian terms I mean we think of
that as a method call but an oo Theory
it's seen as message passing
and in some cases we can say that hey
this role like derives from another role
and we can use Dynamic dispatch to
basically make sure that we effectively
root stuff to the correct derived role
instead
but oo tends to rely on an approach we
call call and return
now that just means you have a main
method which is the entry point and
everything effectually proceeds from
calls from the main method to other
things right
service orientation
SOA was really this idea of taking
object orientation
and if you like doing it at a macro
level to produce a system
so our services
were roles within our system
and they had responsibilities and they
were defined Often by operations rather
than methods but the same thing really
the behaviors in the system
and typically what we would do is
co-locate operations and the state
require to fulfill those operations
within the system
and so effectively
um
they are effectively if you think about
them operation at methods on a class and
often when we built something like a
soap service that's exactly what we did
right we went and worm created a class
just gave it some markup and exposed it
via effective release soap
and the problem with that kind of design
is what we bring with us
is this kind of call and return model
so we bring this idea of there ought to
be some kind of main method that is
actually going to initiate these call to
these things that abstract entities and
behavior so typically what happens is we
have some kind of API Gateway layer
which orchestrates the work amongst all
of these entity services that we own or
we might have some Saga pattern living
in some external command processor and
these things have a couple of problems
they become bottlenecks quite quickly
and they externalize an amount of our
logic away from The Individual Services
into this God thing that basically
represents the main method in our
distributed system
and often we find ourselves not with a
truly distributed system but just a
distributed monolith no matter how hard
we try
the other problem with these systems is
that because they typically use RPC
style synchronous conversation be that
soap grpc even HTTP plus Json
they're not resilient to failure
if we lose an individual service
then the operation being orchestrated
from the Gateway or The Saga often
basically stops working
so the question is can we look at say
reactive programming
which in the 1970s was an alternative
proposal to oo as the way forward in
programming
and see if actually has any insights
that lead to better system design and a
lot of what's happened in these sort of
past 10 years or so is that people have
said hey the reactive programming people
although they didn't win the programming
War actually had some really good ideas
and maybe we should think about
basically what they were saying
all right
so reactive programming really starts
something called data flow programming
which comes from somebody called Jack
Dennis
Jackman writes the first paper the ideas
have been floating around for a while in
various academic circles
and what Jack says is we should see our
program
as a series of nodes that represent
operations or transformations to data
and a series of arcs that move between
those nodes that represent data flowing
between those nodes
hence the name data flow programming
right
so rather than encapsulating State and
behavior together
we separate it we say effectively
actually
we want to have Behavior we want to flow
the state through those behaviors where
it will be transformed
so when we think about
one of these nodes
they have a typical set of
characteristics
they tend to have an input pool and an
output port
sometimes more than one which allows
data to flow into the node for the
transformation and transform data to
flow out
and that node is basically unit of
computation
under data flow programming
a node is activated or fired because
there is data waiting on a port
and therefore that causes it to come
into existence it comes into existence
it's fired it processes that data and it
pushes an answer at The Far Side
the data packets the data packets
effectively can be anything dataflow
programming doesn't really say too much
about them it can be structured
unstructured and maybe effectively evil
include other data packets
and these arcs
you can look at them as pipes and they
connect various nodes
now there are a couple of different
models in dataflow programming supports
one is a synchronous model
in which essentially these arcs are not
buffered they don't have a capacity and
data just basically moves through all of
the nodes
if you buffer the arcs though right so
the arcs effectively have a capacity
they can hold a certain number of pieces
of data at waiting
then that allows us essentially
to parallelize the operation because
each node can run
and process basically the work in its
buffer put work on the other buffer at a
different rate
to other nodes right so each node can
independently run spin along eating and
putting stuff outside and they can
operate in parallel
we are constrained by the slowest node
in the pipeline in terms of our
throughput
but we are able to effectively run all
these nodes independently provided we
have some kind of notion of buffering
okay
um in the classic Model basically I
think we mentioned earlier effectively
the lifetime is essentially just there's
work waiting to be done and we basically
don't have a node when there's no work
waiting to be done
there's no
what we do is we don't activate a node
in order to basically read input
and this effectively acts as a form of
back pressure
it says if the downstream from me is at
capacity
potentially because it's working much
slower than I am
don't read new
items of data from the input
just leave them where they are
so I won't activate the node and that
creates back pressure which stops
effectively us filling up the buffers
too much if we are effectively going too
fast
and the big Advantage is the perception
that data flow programming is data
coupling
so when we think about coupling there's
kind of a chain of tightness to
looseness
so content is essentially
I know how your code works
common is we share some Global state
control is you send some feature flags
and stuff that configure my behavior
down with you
stamp is I may not use all of the fields
of the data that you're sending me so
essentially there's potentially a risk
that if I wanted to drop that field or
Etc I might not know if we're stamp
coupled that you whether you don't use
it
and data coupling effectively is the is
like the best form of coupling we can we
have which is you just couple to the
shape of the data that you use
so these nodes are effectively at least
stamp coupled and probably if we're
doing a good job data coupled which
means that there's low coupling between
these nodes
all right
actors
so traditionally when we in programming
used to try and deal with the problem of
access to a mutable resource in the
presence basically of wanting to scale
what would happen is people would
basically introduce multiple threads to
scale but then have to use some kind of
synchronization primitive to control
access to the mutable state
and this sort of multi-threaded
programming as I'm sure most of you have
done at some point in your life is
typically error-prone and problematic
so Carl Hewitt
created the actor model as a kind of
variation of data flow programming in
order to try and solve this problem of
how do I scale without running into the
problem of synchronization Primitives
so an actor is really just a node in
data flow programming
it's a single threaded node and
essentially it has a mail box which you
can think as a buffered input
which allows a single thread to Simply
chew its way through a set of work and
it may effectively then control a
mutable piece of State because it's
always going to pry change that mutable
state in order and you don't need a
synchronization primitive
okay
in the actor model then actors can send
messages from one actor to another actor
each actor has a unique address
and we can effectively use that address
to send messages to it we get messages
we get addresses for other actors
because we created it it was passed
across or it passed to us on a message
so the model in the actor model creates
a dynamic graph
you don't have to have a fixed graph at
the beginning
we can essentially create the graph as
we go
a key aspect here is basically it lets
us effectively create
partitioned data in order to scale
so F effectively I want to scale
shopping carts
and I effectively own shopping cart
state in one of my nodes
and the problem will be that I can read
messages for all of the shopping carts
that I own in that in say node two
and I can process them in sequence
but I may get overwhelmed at that point
because a number of messages waiting in
my inbox and my single thread that I
have running in my node
makes it may mean that I get a huge
amount of latency and lag processing
those shopping carts
sorry to Partition
and by partitioning what I mean is that
effectively I add another no processing
shopping cart and it's going to have
shopping carts one to twenty and node
two is going to have shopping carts 21
to 40. right
and that enables me then to you to scale
single threaded nodes by scaling out
but note that effectively what I need to
do is partition but it's okay because
the parent that creates the sub nodes
understands effectively
where the shopping carts live because it
was the thing that did the partitioning
in the first place
let's look at flow-based programming
so flow-based programming is another
reactive programming approach
and this came out of Jay Paul Morrison
in the 70s
so in flow-based programming again we
have a node
and the node has an import and an output
and we have connectors between the notes
in flow-based programming connectors are
always buffered
we are always asynchronous when we are
using flow-based programming it does not
allow
us to use essentially a uh a
non-buffered synchronous approach
basically to our data flow
okay data flows are typically push or
pull so a push based by data flow tends
to say work is essentially given to your
your graph and a pool based one says I
Yank on the graph so one poles and one
receives
um
rather than data what flow-based
programming talks about is an
information packet
and information packets flow between
nodes through ports and it's this work
of data throwing through transforms that
basically gets work done
let's have a known lifetime
so packets essentially are only exist
for their time on the pipe what happens
is that when a notice successfully read
a job off basically the import and done
its work it deletes that work that it's
done and it puts something on the out
right so we've actually garbage collect
packets is what Flobots programming
refers to it as
node allows us to do a couple of flow
based programs let's just do a couple of
things when effectively our buffer
begins to fill up
oh that's the next slide but I'll just
one first all right yeah node basically
says uh yeah rather than just saying
activation is the only work on the input
Port is the only it activates our or no
Focus programming says hey it may be
expensive to start up a node
so you can start up a node and keep it
running
and it will just pull things off the
buffered
uh connector
and that allows basically under the
flow-based programming model has to have
long live nodes
in terms of capacity as well as the back
pressure we saw earlier with data flow
programming
where essentially we say if there is no
room on the output Channel don't read
from the input Channel flow-based
programming also introduced the idea of
load shedding
it said
hey if we get too much work coming in
for the output we can simply drop it on
the floor take the packet delete it and
don't do the work
now you may say wow that's going to be
I'm losing all my work but there are
certain circumstances where that might
be quite valuable so
uh I work today in the kind of food
delivery business so think of something
like Drive notifications the driver
notifying you continuously where they
are right if you're getting a lot of
information and you're being overwhelmed
you can drop some of those because all
that happens is the driver will just
seem to jump on the map
and flow less smoothly because you
effectively only get every fifth one Etc
but that's usually acceptable in the
presence of load so as well as back
pressure the other thing flow based
programming tends to teach us is that we
can do load shedding
okay
a couple other interesting things in
flowbase programming
so flightless programming introduces
this idea that you could have multiple
ports
ports and inflate program are just named
things and the idea in the program is
basically you address something by name
and effectively the framework handles
how actually a port works you have no
real understanding of that you just know
that you connect to you send something
to out or other out and you receive
things from in right
multiple writers can write to an import
and that allows us to effectively to
receive signals from multiple places but
we only have one thread writing to Any
Given outpour internally in flow-based
programming
language programming uh in about 2010 j4
Morrison had long retired uh he pointed
out then that you know he was looking at
the kind of modern era uh well it didn't
exist when he when he created flow-based
programming he saw a message or into
middleware as a perfectly valid way of
implementing the connectors that
flowbase programming had talked about
and the flowbase programming could be
seen in the large
as a way of basically building
distributed systems
um
fluidways programming also different in
an initial information packet there's
only when I start up I have a specific
queue
from which I can grab a message which
tells me how to configure myself at
startup
interestingly enough anyone who's worked
with mqtt mqtt which is quite often used
with devices running on unreliable
connections has a very similar model
these are not an iot you can you start
up effectively in mqtt has a model of
taking an initial information packing
and configuring yourself
it also has the notion of control
packets
so the idea in flow-based programming is
if I have a particularly large message I
want to chunk up into a stream on the
port I sent you an initial control
packet which tells you to expect to
stream and how many chunks I think are
going to be in there sends you the
chunks and then sends you effectively a
control packet to tell you the stream is
done
and you can basically you know move on
to the next item
um often basically control packets are
referred to inflow waste program is
brackets it's idea that I'm putting
parenthesis about the things that are
about to come down the pipeline all very
useful ideas
okay
the other thing in flow-based
programming of course is that basically
it one of the things it tries to look at
is this question of
uh well if basically everything is done
by flowing from one node to the next
node
what happens if my node
needs information
in order to process
the data it's received where does it get
it from
so in flowbase programming right there's
no notion of I can make a method call to
that thing over there which in a
distributed system is the equivalent and
we'll see again later of me saying I'm
going to make an HTTP get or a grp
sequel to get something in a messaging
environment
so Morrison's solution and flow-based
programming is well all the component B
needs to do here in this in this diagram
is have a port that effectively listens
to signals
and Bill from from a and effectively
builds a lookup table and here we
actually can see it as potentially a
node that effectively listens to that
builds a lookup table that b uses
okay
and that means that effectively when a
has a change a produces basically a data
packet on its node saying hey the
information you need to look up has
changed
and then effectively we pass it across
to the lookup no which watch it into the
table that b then uses to reference
stuff
so in a distributed system this is this
idea effectively that you know I want to
look up customers or restaurants or
Brokers or some kind of kind of
reference data and what I do is wait for
the system that produces that to produce
a data packet which and then I can use
to build a lookup
all right
so how do we apply some of these
reactive programming Concepts to build
larger systems and why does
reactive Manifesto talk about this idea
is of message passing resilience
elasticity and responsiveness right how
does this actually work
to produce stuff
so the idea in a reactive systems
is to model ourselves in the same way we
do in reactive programming
we think of our services as nodes
that receive data
and there's a very much a flow-based
programming model of it must be
basically an asynchronous connector
we receive data on some asynchronous
connector so Kafka driver mq sqs as your
service bus take your pick right
we then do perform some kind of
transformation
and we pass the data down the line
the advantage of message passing and the
buffering it offers us in an
asynchronous conversation is that both
parties do not need to be present for a
conversation to succeed
so think about the kind of way you tend
to organize a night out with your
friends right
it's much easier to have them in a
WhatsApp group or on slack or Twitter DM
any problem usually being they're all
chosen something else to communicate
with them than it is to basically phone
them all up right if you phone them
you're a bit dependent on them being
there to pick up the phone when you when
you phone them right send them a message
they can look at it in the next 10
minutes when they're free
and it's exactly the same reason why we
tend to prefer asynchronous
conversations
right because someone could pick up the
message when they're ready it's the idea
of having a mailbox
so reactive systems borrow this idea
from flow-based programming
of having a service
that has a buffered connector on which
it receives an incoming message into
which it puts an outgoing message
and those Services much like nodes
rather than being SOA style oh I
maintain State and I maintain data
should be much more a data flow
programming style model which says I
make a transformation to the data in
some way typically we tend to think of
them as being a verb or noun combination
like place an order or onboard a
restaurant
and workflows to specific use cases
are usually data flying between a number
of nodes which perform individual
Transportation steps
okay the information packets we tend to
think of as commands sometimes nowadays
folks say messaging
which essentially are things that I'm
being told
could be an instruction it could be
effectively
um a a request
right
or events which are facts
things about the past that I've often
done
so we think about the flow it may be
that I receive a command do some work
and then push a command to the next node
in the flow
or maybe that I receive a command I do
some work and then I communicate an
event which describes what happened or
it may well be most commonly I do both
so basically if I get a purchase request
I may have a node that basically does
some checkout processing which involves
pricing basically that item and then I
may say hey I need the payment system
take a payment for this so I will send
it a command it will basically then take
a payment for me
much like data flow programming
and reactive architectures we tend to
recommend that you think about these
Services as being single threaded and
scale them out
one of the advantages of being single
threaded as a course that you can
maintain ordering as soon as you have a
multi-threaded service you will lose
ordering because you can't you're
de-ordering the buffer as soon as you
read from it
that also implies that you would need to
Partition
that's why things like Kafka work on a
partition basis right
if you don't care about ordering you can
use more of a competing consumers
approach where multiple individual
single threaded workers read from a
given buffer
so we are thinking about what we do idea
of coordinating data flow we partition
our system and by that we mean how do we
slice it up into individual parts
to create a continuous steady flow of
information
typically you want to look for things
that represent if you like processing
steps often a really good model is to
look for processing steps that are
paralyzable
I can do this
and I can pass it down the line I can
then do another one of this or someone
else does the later step
these two steps don't need to be done
together so I can break them apart and I
can paralyze them
what would the inside of a node look
like so here we're going to basically
step away slightly
um from some of the reactive people and
look at some work by Pat Helen anyone
know who pays a few of you
so that's really important in the kind
of service space he also was the guy
that created Ms DTC worked on tandem
non-stop later said let's not do
distributed transactions anymore
um uh and his work basically effectively
includes things that generate ideas like
outboxes Etc
so Pat's got a um uh reasonably recent
paper out called autonomous components
you should probably read if you're
interested in some of these ideas
so Pat basically says that effectively
what happens in a typical node
is that a note has an explicit boundary
right which is basically the ports if
you like from our reactive model so
explicitly you have these ports where we
communicate with the outside world what
I mean by ports essentially something
that basically says here is a definition
of a message that I send or receive
um and here's the protocol I'm going to
receive it on
um and here's any additional information
about what might go in headers Etc that
I need you to worry about right
and so that's an explicit boundary that
we communicate we receive messages in
over basically one of these ports
internally your code it should probably
be abstracted from you and you send one
to a port basically
have a message I can't see my screen
anymore
okay I think someone's saying that I'm
obscuring the antenna on the mic
um
so uh
having received basically a message on
one of these ports
um uh we tend to kick off what's called
an activity
so an activity is really just your code
and some state that your code needs
so the idea is let's say that
effectively I am pricing an order I
would say okay great I have got
basically this activity pricing an order
that I'm going to kick off
I would record usually the incoming
message which says I've received a
message requiring pricing for this
basket
and that resource is basically the
basket that I am pricing okay
and then typically my activity May well
be some kind of state machine that has a
number of steps
so perhaps validating pricing and then
essentially what I may need to do
is coordinate later steps in the
workflow
so I act effectively as an orchestrator
I don't need to have an external Saga
from a command process from a message
processor I don't need to have basically
an API Gateway doing that I know that
essentially this thing needs to take a
payment
and at that point effectively I will
save my state so that I can be resumed
and I will call out to another service
sending it a command basically across a
an output and wait for a response
when I call out it is important that
effectively I have probably updated the
state of my basket to say it is awaiting
effectively payment
that essentially I coordinate that with
sending the message
on the output
and that leads this idea of
transactional messaging
it's going to be a problem if I update
the resource the basket in our example
to say that it is awaiting payment that
is the state I have reached if I never
send the message
because my broker
could fail to send the message and I
can't include it in some kind of
distributed transaction because
typically it doesn't support the same
DTC coordinator
and transactional messaging I typically
write both to the outbox the message I
intend to send
and a change to the resource indicating
what state I've moved it to where it's
now pending a message that means I
clearly know in my state hey I've got a
basket waiting for a pricing request and
here is the message I sent to get
pricing
okay
now the trouble with my outbox is
that I can't always know whether the
failure to send to the broker was
because the broker didn't respond
telling me it actually had sent the
message
or whether the broker effectively hadn't
sent the message at all it's a problem
with distributed systems right I can't
know that the lack of a response was a
failure of the communication between me
and the broker or whether essentially it
was due to the fact that it genuinely
couldn't send something
so that means I may have to resend from
my outbox
when something essentially
is not marked as dispatched and because
it could actually have been dispatched
that means I will send duplicates
that's why we tend to refer to
guaranteed at least once delivery when
we talk about this model of
transactional messaging because I can
guarantee I send it to you by keeping
basically uh polling that out box to see
what needs to be sent and sending it
until I mark it dispatched but at the
risk that the freighter Market
dispatched was an error and effectively
had been dispatched
so that tends to lead to me needing to
an inbox
which says what have I already seen
and if I've already seen it
I cannot do the work I can de-duplicate
and that leads us to have a model where
effectively with inside our service we
typically have an inbox messages I'm
receiving and an outbox message as I've
sent
Pat's point is that essentially in some
cases that may be all the state that you
need
because you can determine the state of
an operation that is actually happening
with inside your node
by simply looking at the messages you've
sent and the messages you've received
you know exactly where you are in a
given workflow so if you're not managing
the state of a particular resource
you can still persist effectively the
state of a workflow
without necessarily requiring to manage
the workflow explicitly
so the inbox has told me what I've
received so I know how far I got
provided the outbox message has been
sent that corresponds to that step
foreign
so here you can see the model that I'm
using is I'm saying okay at checkout I'm
going to go through validation pricing
request payment at that point
effectively I need to basically send a
message to the next node Downstream
which takes the payment that may be very
good for me to actually make that
basically a parallelizable unit because
it may well be calling a external
payment provider which may be down for
some reason which may have to basically
be a synchronous interaction so I would
like to effectively make it asynchronous
by buffering my request to it
right when it is done
I receive a payment made message and
typically by a correlation ID or natural
correlation ID like the order ID when I
received that back I can effectively go
and see what state my activity and reach
for that given order
and then move it on to purchase made
and then I may raise basically another
message out of my node saying there is a
new order
and these activities are what govern
code and these activities replace the
need for external
um
processes that essentially like sagas or
API gateways
and errors is just a similar flow right
when we talk about business errors
particularly payment refused it's just
another Port that effectively take
payment can use that essentially results
in me as an activity saying hey I need
to send a message saying you know give
me a new card
because of the buffering
between the nodes
we are resilient to failure of a node
if a node fails we simply queue work
when the node resumes it'll pick up work
from the buffer
and just continue processing as normal
and we say this gives us bulkheads to
failure
so think of a ship ship has various a
series of compartments if one of those
compartments is hold although it floods
the Ship Won't sink the other
compartments keep it up keep it afloat
similarly our system won't collapse
because we simply lose a node which may
be a transient failure we'll just
restart one right with uh Lambda or
kubernetes
when we bring it back up it can pull the
messages off the buffer
one of the problems that people get into
is that people try to effectively break
out of this reactive model
into a more classic oo model and make a
call to some kind of pricing component
at this point saying hey well this node
needs to get the price so I'm going to
make basically a call to try and get
that directly and typically the concern
we have is that you make some kind of
HTTP get from with inside your checkout
service saying oh can you just get me
the price of this or you know can you
check the pricing that the customer has
put in the basket is actually still
correct
so you may or may not know but the
reason the Titanic sank
was because although the Titanic had
bulkheads
they didn't have bulkheads up to the top
of the ship because that would have
interrupted the ability of the first
class passengers to Promenade along
their deck showing off their fine
clothing so the bulk had stopped which
meant that when the basic one of the
compartments flooded it over topped and
began to basically fill the bolt the the
part the compartments next to it leading
to the Titanic sinking and essentially
when you have an asynchronous message
passing reactive architecture and you
choose to make HTTP gets you are
effectively allowing the first class
passengers to Promenade upon your deck
and you will sink when you hit an
iceberg
right so learn from the Titanic and
don't do that
so we know what the answer is to this
model right we looked at it in
flow-based programming
one or two options the first is simply
it's another node that I talk to I send
a message saying hey please price this
for me and it gives me a response back
saying here is the price right
just another basically uh message that I
send and my activity is suspended and I
record something in my outbox and then
something in my inbox
the other alternative is what pattern
calls a reference data which is that
lookup model I listen to messages
basically from some kind of pricing
component which is giving me a catalog
and I have that locally and I can use
that to look up the pricing information
the way I often talk about this is you
know it's a bit the equivalent of uh my
customer I send them a physical catalog
which has prices and the Agents that
take calls for customers for order have
the same catalog and they can confirm
the prices
so typically what one this is a very
common model for us it's called event
card State transfer when we do it by
messaging is to say let's listen to the
new catalog messages store them locally
in the checkout component and use it as
a lookup
okay
now of course this does make us
eventually consistent
because we may have stale prices
but reactive talks about this trade-off
between eventual consistency often
thought of as latency
right and resilience or availability and
we typically we are trading off having
available system for one that basically
may have to cope with eventual
consistency and there's usually a simple
solution for example the customer tell
you on the customer's basket you
understand what version of pricing
catalog the front end was using and then
when you come to price if it turns out
your latest version in your local table
is basically an earlier version of the
catalog you typically just delay your
processing until effective that one
filters through
the other thing that's quite common when
we think about reactive in this model of
resiliency is the idea of implementing
the let it crash pattern or crash only
software
so the idea behind crash only software
is that we can spend an enormous amount
of time trying to figure out how to make
our software resilient to failure but
often that failure is transient
difficult to recover from because we're
at depth and Recovery may actually
attempts at recovery may put us in a
worse or very more much more complicated
position
so the let it crash pattern is the idea
that we just say hey in the event of
some kind of exceptional failure we just
simply crash our component
right it's the it's the software
architecture version have you have you
tried turning on or off again right
so if you implement this approach what
you begin to realize is that when I
restart up
one of the things I have to do is accept
that I may have terminated because I
crashed and the first thing I should do
is attempt to recover
anything that was potentially in flight
now if we think about the model we were
talking about right we tend to have
everything we need in a reactive system
to do that
provided I never act or acknowledge in
other words basically allow effectively
an offset to be committed or a message
to be listed off a queue for the
connector that comes into my component
I will never effectively have reached
the point where I've updated my state to
show it processed
until I've completed that action so if I
crash halfway through
that message will be still available and
waiting on my buffer for me to process
next time I start up
my resource has only been updated
prior to my effectively acting that
message
my inbox helps me against duplicated
requests
and my outbox will tell me what I
intended to send
and those allow me
to have a model where I say just crash
it just crash it and we'll recover the
work when we start up
yeah okay
so again we also need to think about
this model of kind of push and pull or
back pressure on load shedding right
we may have the option with the
middleware we're using select push or
pull
push would effectively say give us the
messages as they arrive
and Paul would say we will Poll for them
in order to basically with pop but
polling it is much easier to control
back pressure
because you can stop requesting when
you're full enough with push it's a
little bit harder
because the thing Upstream will keep
shoving you messages so one of the
problems you'll meet with something like
AWS Lander
is it's going to keep pushing to your
component
you don't have the capacity to apply
back pressure
your main your main choice at that point
is load shedding
so when you want to apply back pressure
what you need to be able to do is
control your ability
to consume stuff and better pause it if
you need to
a circuit breaker is if you like a model
where effectively we say we think there
is a transient error
crashing probably won't help us we'll
just restart and still hit this thing
that's a transient error the database is
not available the payment provider's
gone down
so what we'll do is essentially we will
temporarily stop consuming messages
then we'll let a test one through if
that one works then we'll turn on the
Taps and start and start moving
so circuit breakers are really useful in
this model because they essentially say
apply back pressure
stop consuming from the buffer
but also be aware that load shedding
just as in you know flow-based
programming is a valid alternative at
this point right
if it doesn't matter that Downstream
doesn't receive information from you
because it's likely to be out of date if
you passed it on in a while simply drop
the load at that point
so in order to mean responsive
you will need to scale because typically
the model we are looking for is to make
these Services single threaded so that
essentially we don't have any problems
with concurrency
so when you scale out obviously you have
a couple of options typically with
messaging there's the competing
consumers model where effectively it
says the ordering doesn't matter I'm
reading for some kind of queue each
worker item can be action independently
I I can just scale up by introducing new
ones that read the same buffer right so
if I've got a basket and it needs
pricing it isn't impacted by the pricing
with any other baskets in the queue so I
can just use a Queue at that point and I
can scale out of our competing consumers
by adding additional consumers of that
basically that of those messages
if ordering is important right perhaps I
basically have changes that essentially
need to be applied in sequence in order
to make sense
I may be using a stream with Kafka for
example to preserve ordering not only to
Partition
typically the middleware the broker will
handle partitioning for you by scheme
known as consistent hashing which means
effectively it will always tend to give
the same worker things that basically
hash to the same range
and the advantage of scaling tends to be
that if something has a fault
we may already have other items that are
able to take over the load of the
processing
and so we remain responsive even the
event of failure
we can also effectively you know
typically restart something to replace
that one quite quickly in a modern
environment
routing is really this one is basically
about the fact that if we are single
threaded we need to politician which I
mentioned earlier right and being single
threaded inside these components which
is something that I think throws a few
people because they tend to have you
know thread pools dealing with work etc
it's hugely advantageous it's
significantly simplifies your
programming model
and if you're reading from a queue you
can be single threaded
because you just scale by introducing
new instances or partitioning basically
effectively to allocate to new ones
all right
so just to kind of recap
when we think about reactive systems
we are borrowing from the ideas
basically they're expressed by reactive
programming
where effectively want to focus on the
flow through the system
and we think of nodes which program
which which are processing steps and
have data flowing between them
as opposed to a kind of oosoa model
where we think about data and behavior
being co-located
and within basically a system scale
rather than a programming scale
we think about that being message driven
so we use basically messaging middleware
and that messaging
connector or buffer right
I'll just be resilient to failure by
giving us bulkheads
and it allows us to be elastic because
we can introduce new single threaded
processes of basically of those
connections either by partitioning or
competing consumers
which allow us to continue to be
responsive to our users even in the
event of failure
all right
and that is that
I've got like four minutes uh if there
are so if there are any questions
um you can always outcome and ask
questions at the bottom afterwards and I
do take DMS on Twitter
hopefully that is a bit of an
understanding of what people mean when
they talk about a reactive architecture
it's one that's basically message
message driven which gives you elastic
resilience and responsiveness and it's
using those reactive programming
Concepts
you don't have to use an active
framework to build a reactive
architecture that's one of the things
you should take away as well right they
are very useful but you can build
reactive voltages with any system that
involves message passing and notes
all right I can't see any questions
although I am Blinded By the Light oh
there's one at the front
okay
so the question was does grpc fit well
into the model no is the answer so grpc
effectively is a synchronous
conversation between two components
in the event that basically you lose one
component you can't base your
conversation breaks
so uh messaging gives you that basically
buffer which means you can be
asynchronous
any other questions
I think there's one over here oh gosh we
have to shout
my friend
when it comes to the control packets
brackets do they send check the back
pressure
of the next note against the expected
size of the packages in the control
brackets it is it expects to send or
does it work some other magic way
now the question really is about
basically the ability to apply back
pressure so interactive programming you
have slight advantage in the sense that
you'll tend to know the capacity of your
buffer and you'll tend to be able to
understand that the buffer is full
in a reactive system you don't tend to
have that so easily because you don't
really know the capacity of the
community may not have a capacity so
what you're looking at more is your
input buffer to you when you are
receiving messages and how fast or slow
you want to go so it is basically the
consumer
that needs to control the rate that's
why polling is easier than pushing
because by polling you can say stop I'm
not I'm not going to take any more if
it's push you have to have a mechanism
to say for the push mechanism please
don't give me any more until I ask you
to give me more again right so you can't
you've got to have to suspend the push
until basically it comes back so Kafka
for example has polling out the box so
it's very straightforward as there's
something like sqs which works basically
over HTTP anyway something like rabbit
well if actually pushes an option it
works but you have to basically suspend
being pushed to when effectively you
decide that you've got too much capacity
in which case it's a bit like being a
circuit breaker you say hey stop sending
me stuff right now right
oh question over there
okay so the question basically is
keeping track of all my nodes and data
to queue something else so observability
is your is is what you have to do with
any distributed system right you have to
move to a world of logs metrics and
traces Trace is particularly
um for systems that basically work in
this kind of way because you get to see
basically the spans and activities and
you can see where stuff moves inside its
workflow but yeah
um you need to start investing in
observability if you are going to use
this approach